en fait une mathieu été victime d'une
véritable adulation c'était il ya
quelques jours qui est totalement
déplorable inqualifiable été agressé
verbalement par un chauffeur de taxi
s'est fait sortir de son taxi et je ne
reprendrai pas les les termes match on
n'en a pas parlé mais closer a été
informée par qui par quoi on se demande
on a une petite idée et je trouve que
c'est d'abord parce qu'il ya une plainte
il ya une plainte qui a été déposée par
par mathieu donc il ya j'espère une
issue favorable à cette pelote et qui se
mènent leurs fesses voilà alors alors
non mais alors je vais vous dire là je
prends la guerre je prend la défense de
personnes déjà mathieu ça vraiment ça me
fait ça c'est très bon match et c'est
terrible ce qui lui est arrivé et on le
soutiendra toujours et mathieu vous
savez que je serai toujours là pour vous
vraiment tu le sais mon chéri tu sais
comme je t'aime wallon sao closer lent
c'est leur silence et leur boulot
benjamin oui désolé alors souhaitait pas
en parler pourquoi pour d'abord
j'aimerais tant des îles qui les a
informés
oui mais bon voilà oui mais à closer
c'est leur boulot moi je trouve que
closer en plus et voilà ils sont plutôt
il voit là ils sont ils sont pas hyper
trash c'est quoi exactement l'info qui
sortent notamment sur la guerre est une
chose
dieu sait si j'aime la police j'ai été
reçue au commissariat mais mais comme
une star que je ne suis pas ils ont pris
la plainte ils ont été adorables et tard
dans des locaux mieux cesser je soutiens
toujours la police est vraiment mais
vraiment de tout mon coeur et
heureusement qu'ils sont là
il ya juste une question que je me pose
je porte plainte à 00h30
le soir on est quatre dans un
commissariat appelle tap le truc et tout
ça c'est une jeune fille je sors du
commissariat et à 7 heures du matin j'ai
un coup de téléphone de closer qui me
dit exactement la plainte que j'ai dicté
que j'ai que j'ai donné au comice à
l'heure le dax il m'a chacune qui seront
posés la question si j'adore la police
mais j'aimerais juste savoir quand même
comment ces sommets matthieu ballet la
réponse est non mais ça c'est la seule
chose qui m'ennuie
après après c'est vrai qu'à des il y
avait là il ya des fuites partout c'est
et c'est vrai que mathieu mine de rien
moi en tout cas ce qui vous est arrivé
ça nous a beaucoup touchés qu'ils
peuvent vraiment voilà et moi je vous
dis que je vous nous faire un petit
business ce gentil à vous
le calme est cette fois je voulais pas
laisser passer
voilà c'est la police c'est peut-être
pas le chauffeur de taxi qui est parti
par closer on veut pas savoir exactement
ce qui s'est passé voilà mais vous avez
une mésaventure
mathieu c'est une agression sinon une
agression et ses précautions
après après ccc comme tout dans cette
émission j'ai parlé de ma vie privée
et puis c'est une mission qui est très
regardé donc forcément bas maintenant il
m'arrive des billets avec tout bonheur
que dans cette émission
parfois en revanche il ya des des
mésaventures alors elles sont souvent
écrites et puis parfois heureusement
malheureusement peu de foi mais parfois
ça arrive tu arrivé deux fois une fois
les arrières vous m'avez appelé et une
fois là il ya quelques jours va parfois
malheureusement c'est physiquement ça
arrive encore
non mais ça vraiment ça c'est
inadmissible l'agencé senora oui pour
pour relever un peu sur le côté
médiatique parce qu'on va parler un peu
de chaleur et closer et puisque j'en ai
discuté avec des policiers c'est que
quand il se passe quelque chose d'un
arrondissement de paris n'importe quel
qui concerne quelqu'un qui est connue
qui est ça qui est très connu
ils ont l'obligation de rapporter la
préfecture de police de paris ce qui
s'est passé concernant la star en
question parce que là si l affaire sans
lendemain faut pas que la préfecture
chaque rue du pont faisant on n'est pas
courant de ce qui s'est passé lors
qu'ils ont l'obligation de tout rapporté
la presse et pas très dur pour les
journalistes d'après après une tournée
en fait il s'est passé un accord des
choses est repris le truc c'est pas du
monde est méchant rhume et de regret
voilà après ils ont été alors par les
maths et jean michel vous donner une
très bonne affirme l'information puisque
c'est vrai qu'il ya un service vip mais
dans les commissariats et des déportés
plein baby mama do with moins un jour on
m'avait volé mon couteau suisse répond
vivement des plaintes been closer
hanouna mais c'est maintenant mais je te
jure que c'est vrai m et voilà donc
voilà je en tout cas on est à fond avec
vous c'est faux de soutiens à fond mon
mathieu tu sais qu'on t'aime très fort
et que ici et avec les téléspectateurs
tués de la famille et qu'on se défendre
à tout
[Applaudissements]